A while ago on my channel, I covered
Crawl forAI, an incredible open- source
tool for you to crawl pretty much any
website to get it into the perfect
format for LLM knowledge for things like
your rag AI agents. And let me just say,
the feedback that I got on that video
was amazing. And so many of you started
using crawl for AI for your own
projects, including myself for Archon,
my open-source AI agent builder. So now
I want to take crawl for AAI much
further with you because a lot of the
questions that you guys had were how to
handle different kinds of websites.
Sometimes we have a sitemap so we can
see the different URLs that we need to
crawl. Other times we have to figure it
out ourselves from the navigation and
then other times we have this new idea
of an LLM.ext where the website gives us
a single page with all the documentation
specifically for us to give to our LLMs.
And so right now I'm going to show you
how to handle all of these different
scenarios with Crawl forAI so that no
matter what kind of knowledge you want
to bring into your LLMs, you can do that
in seconds. So here is the homepage for
the Crawl for AI documentation. I'll
have a link to this in the description
as well because this is my resource for
all of the code that I have created that
I'll show you throughout this video. And
I covered this on my channel before.
I've talked about Crawl for AI, but a
lot has changed and this project has
completely blown up recently. Take a
look at this. It's completely open
source, so it's on GitHub. And the repo
currently has 42,000 stars, which is
just amazing. People are realizing that
this tool is just the best at what it
does. And scraping the internet to
create knowledge for our LLMs is really
important because a lot of the knowledge
we give our agents comes from the
internet. So, we need a way to scrape
that effectively and to do it quickly.
And Crawl for AI definitely gives us
both of those things. It is blazing
fast, as we'll see in some of my demos
that I have for you in a bit. And it
produces webpage data that is AI ready.
It spits out what's called markdown
format, which is just the optimal format
for LLMs to understand these pages and
pick out distinct sections from them.
And if you're curious how projects like
Context 7 are able to scrape up-to-date
documentation constantly to provide that
to AI coding assistants, I can guarantee
that they're using something like crawl
for AAI. And it wouldn't surprise me if
they actually are using crawl for AAI to
scrape all the documentation for
Superbase and Fast API, MCP, Nex.js, all
these different libraries because it's
so fast and so efficient. And it's also
what I use for Archon, my AI agent
builder, like I mentioned in the intro,
which speaking of Archon, I have some
big updates for that slash potential
changes of plans that I definitely want
to get your feedback on. So, if you're
interested in Archon, please stay tuned
for the end of this video. I want to
share some things with you on that. But
right now I want to focus on crawl for
AAI. And then in the documentation for
crawl for AI on their homepage they have
a quick start that shows us at a high
level how we can build this crawler and
then use it to crawl pretty much any URL
that we give it. It is so easy to use
this. And then within their installation
instructions we can see just how easy it
is to set this up. You just have to have
Python installed and then you can pip
install crawl for AI and then run their
setup command to install the playright
browser so that your terminal can run a
browser to scrape pages under the hood
and do the rest of the necessary setup.
So that's all you have to run to get
things set up and then I can show you
that within my windsurf here I have a
first example to show you really quickly
which is definitely inspired by the
quick start that we just saw. So I
create this instance of an async web
crawler through crawl for AAI. And then
the URL that I'm having it scrape is the
Pantic AI documentation. And so going
back to my browser here, I'll show you
that this is the page that we are about
to scrape with crawl for AI. And I could
just take the raw HTML of this page and
give it to an LLM, but it's not going to
be able to pick out different sections
very well and just understand the page
as well as if we give it the markdown
format. And I'll show you in a second
exactly what that looks like when we run
this script. And so this page right here
is what we're going to transform into
LLM knowledge. And so I have my terminal
open. Um and I'm going to just run that
exact same script that I just showed
you. And on top of getting this
beautiful markdown format that you'll
see in a second, you'll also see just
how fast that is. Just take a look at
that. It just in seconds scraped this
entire page and formatted it for us into
something that is much easier for our
agents and LLMs to understand. And so we
have these bullet points and then we
have the markdown where we have the
different headings and the subheadings.
And so everything is just very
structured for our agents. And so that's
my first example just to give you the
basics of how we use crawl for AI. But
now we get to the real stuff because I
want to show you what you really came to
this video for which is scraping entire
websites. Right now, we just crawled a
single page, which it was important for
me to show you a basic example. But what
we really want to do is crawl entire
websites. We want to pull the markdown
for every page that is available to us,
then feed that into our AI agent for rag
so that it can become the expert on our
e-commerce store or understand the full
documentation for something like Pantic
AI, whatever website it is. I have you
covered now with a few different
strategies for crawling really any
website that I'll hit on right now. So
the first main way that you can crawl
websites is through what is called a
sitemap. And so a lot of websites will
make this available where you can go to
the root domain and then slash
sitemap.xml. There are a couple other
different URLs. They might look a little
different, but usually it's going to be
/sitemap.xml. And this is going to give
you this very structured document here
that tells you all the URLs that are
available for you to visit for this
website. And so this is the primary
method in my previous crawl for AI video
that I showed as a way to get access to
all the different web pages that are
available in a given website. But
sometimes you don't always have a
sitemap. This is really convenient and
if it's available to you, you probably
want to use it. But sometimes you don't
have that. And so you need crawl for AAI
to actually start from the homepage and
then find the rest of the pages through
navigation. do some kind of recursive
scraping where it goes through these
pages and finds all the links that it
has to visit. That is the second method
that I have covered for you here. And
then the last method is a lot of
especially documentation for frameworks
and tools. They've started to put out
what's called an
LLMs.ext. And so usually this is going
to be either /lms.ext
orlms-full.ext. And essentially what
they do with this is they take every
single page for their documentation and
they combine it together into a single
page. So we have one document that we
can bring into our program we can chunk
up and add it into our vector database
for rag. So it's literally documentation
formatted and this is all markdown just
like crawl for produces. It's formatted
specifically for LLM knowledge. And so
that is the third method of scraping
data from a website that I'll show you
with crawl for AAI. And essentially one
of these three methods is going to be
able to be used no matter what website
you are crawling. And so I truly am
showing you here how to extract LLM
knowledge from any website that you
want. So your golden ticket to crawl any
web page with any of the three methods
that I shared with you and to do it very
fast is this GitHub repository which I
have as a free resource for you. So link
to this in the description of this
video. And the way that I have
structured this repository is I first
have this crawl for AAI examples folder.
This is where I show you at more a
granular level how we have these
different strategies set up to crawl web
pages in crawl for AI. So first we have
crawling a single page. So this is the
very basic example that I showed you
earlier. Then we have this example that
I don't want to cover too much in this
video but you can crawl web pages
sequentially. So you just process one
URL at a time. But what crawl for AAI
does really well and what makes it
blazingly fast is you can crawl batches
of URLs in parallel. And so that's what
I have for the last three scripts in the
examples folder here. So starting with
the script to crawl our site maps. This
is going to take that site map like this
is the one that we have for crawl for
AAI that we saw earlier and it's going
to take batches of these URLs and
extract them markdown from each of them
in parallel. So we can then feed that
into our vector database for our rag
knowledge base. I know it's very meta
here. We're using crawl for AAI to crawl
crawl for AI. But I mean, yeah, this is
good documentation to crawl and get into
our AI coding assistance and things like
that because we definitely want to
create a lot of agents around this. So
that's for sitemaps. Then we have the
one to crawl our LLM.ext. So this is
just going to take a single URL. It's a
lot simpler because the LLM's.ext is
just one page with all of the
documentation. And I do show you in this
script how to chunk things as well
because obviously we would not want to
take this massive document and dump that
into a prompt for the LLM. And so we
want to chunk that up. And so then that
leads us to our last one here. And this
is the most complex but also the most
flexible because we can give it any
website URL. It doesn't have to be an
LLM.ext. It doesn't have to be a
sitemap. and it can scrape the homepage
or whatever that page is that we gave it
and then intelligently determine other
links to other parts of this web page
and scrape those as well. And it does it
in a recursive way where we can specify
the depth like how many levels we want
it to go down. So it can search for all
the different URLs that we have for this
web page. So it can scrape everything
essentially as if we gave it a
sitemap.xml. So very very powerful
stuff. The sponsor of today's video is
Aqua Voice, an insanely powerful and
accurate AI voice system that works on
any application on your Mac or Windows
computer. You just have to install Aqua
Voice once and you can use it anywhere
with literally the press of a button.
Take a look at this. Archon is my AI
agent builder that uses Crawl for AI,
Pideantic AI, and Superbase. And then I
let go of the button and look at how
fast that was and also how accurate it
is as well with words like pyantic AI
and crawl for AI that usually these
voice systems would completely botch.
And talking numbers, Aqua will start up
in around 50 milliseconds and get you
responses in as fast as 450
milliseconds. And it makes 17 times
fewer mistakes than Siri and Google
voice typing. So you get insane speed
and accuracy. And I have not seen
something as smooth as this before. And
my favorite way to use Aqua is within my
AI coding assistants like Windsurf
because Aqua has this feature called
deep context where it can view your
screen to understand what you're
currently working on. So it can
reference certain components of your
code, spell things correctly, really
help you communicate effectively with
your AI IDE. For example, update my
async webcrawler call to use the browser
config that I imported from crawl for
AAI in line 2. And boom, it spelled
everything correctly like my async
webcrawler, browser config. It really
understands the code that I'm working on
so I can communicate effectively with
Windsurf. And within the Aqua app, you
can tweak your settings. You can toggle
deep context on and off. Add things to
your dictionary so it dictates it
properly. Give custom instructions based
on different applications. There's so
much control that you have here. And
then the main component of this GitHub
repository is I created an AI agent that
has this script as well to insert
documents into its knowledge base that
combines all three strategies. So you
can give this script a URL and it will
intelligently determine is this a
sitemap, an LLM.ext or a regular web
page and then use that specific strategy
depending on which type of URL it is.
And then this is all set up with a
pyantic AI rag agent that is using
Chroma DB for its vector database. So I
just wanted something really simple and
that you can run locally. So that's why
I chose Chroma DB. But you could
obviously use Superbase or Quadrant or
Pine Cone something else for your vector
database as well. So a very simple agent
overall just leveraging a tool that will
allow us to search all of this knowledge
that we give to our vector database
through what we crawl with crawl for
AAI. And within the readme that I have
for this repository, I show you how to
get everything up and running. So
prerequisites, installation
instructions, setting up your
environment variables, how you can use
these different scripts to get the
knowledge base set up and to run the
agent itself. So all the instructions
are here and I can actually show you a
demo of this live. So, I'm going to run
the insert docs function and then I'm
going to copy the URL for the sitemap
for crawl for AAI. So, I'm going to send
this in. It's going to determine that it
has to use that first strategy to scrape
everything from a sitemap. And look at
that. We're fetching all of these URLs
in batches. I think I have a batch size
of five or something like that. So, it's
it's scraping five at a time. Doing this
very very quickly. And so there are
quite a few pages that we have for crawl
for AI. It created 457 chunks in total
that it's now inserting into Chroma DB.
And actually basically the insert into
Chroma DB takes longer than the scraping
itself. That is how blazing fast crawl
for AAI is. And we could even make it so
that it batches in sets of 10 or 20. So
it scrapes even faster. And there we go.
We have everything inserted into Chroma
DB. So that process is now done. But
what I can do is just run this another
time, but instead of using the crawl for
ai sitemap, how about this time we use
the pidantic web page. So not a sitemap
or llm's.ext. So I'm going to go ahead
copy this URL, paste it here. Now it'll
say that it detects that it is a regular
web page that it has to crawl. Regular
URL and we'll give it a second and boom,
there we go. It starts with the homepage
and then it checks the navigation. It
looks for what are called internal
links. That's the phrase used with crawl
for AAI to find all the different web
pages. go through there, find even more
links to other parts of the web page.
Really trying to hit on everything. Like
I don't have the sitemap.xml. So if I
have a certain depth, like I go three
levels deep, I'm not absolutely
guaranteed to hit every single web page,
but you can set that depth to something
more like five or six if you want as
well. And then pretty much you are going
to hit on any page you could possibly
have within this website. Especially
things for documentation like Pantic AI
or Langraphph where you're not really
going to go that deep. the navigation on
the lefth hand side usually it's going
to cover most of what's available in the
website and so this takes a little bit
longer overall because it has to do with
more of this recursive searching and so
I will pause and come back once this
scraping is complete and there we go we
are done and this time it inserted
2,420 chunks into chroma so definitely
the podantic documentation is just much
larger than what we have in crawl for AI
and then the very last test we obviously
just want to use an LLM's text. And so
I'm going to remove that link to pantic
AI and then paste in the llm.ext for
langraph, which is my favorite AI agent
framework to orchestrate different
agents together. And so this time it's
going to just pull that single page
instead of going to many different pages
and it's going to chunk that up. So it's
very very fast now. It pulled that one
page, split it into 788 chunks, and now
it's inserting that into Chroma. So I'll
pause and come back again once that is
complete. And there we go. We've
inserted all of our langraph chunks into
Chroma DB. And now I've showed you every
single method. Now I want to demo the
agent to you. Ask it some questions just
to make sure that all the knowledge that
we brought into our agent from call for
AAI is working well. So I have a
streamlet interface created that I show
you how to set up in the readme. So I'm
just going to run the command streamllet
run in the name of my streamllet python
script. This is going to spin up a page
in the browser so we can start talking
to our agent. And it takes a little bit
for the first message to go through
because it has to load the Chroma DB
instance. But otherwise, these messages
get a responses from the agent blazing
fast. So, first I'll have it verify that
it has access to the Piantic AI doc. So,
verify that you have access to the
Pyantic AI doc. So, I'll do a quick
search. Confirm for me that it has
access to the documentation. Good. And
I'll say now confirm Superbase. This is
one where it doesn't actually have that
access. And so, yep, there we go. The
documentation available does not contain
anything about superbase because we only
crawled crawl for AI, pyantic AI and
langraph. And so now I can refresh the
conversation here. I'll just ask it a
simple question about pyantic AI. Just
show me how to create a very basic
agent. And so it doesn't give me a step
by step in the documentation, which is
fine. I don't really expect it to have
that, but I'll just say give me
something very basic here. So just so I
can see that it yeah, it got something
from the documentation. So there we go.
That is looking good. All right. Right.
So, refresh the conversation. Now, we
can try something out with crawl for AI.
So, I'll ask it something basic like how
do I install crawl for AI? We'll see if
it can give me those pip commands like
we saw earlier. Yeah, there we go. So,
crawl for AAI setup. So, all the setup
commands as well. Looking really good.
And then I can do something for
langraph. I could just ask the same
question here. I just want something
really basic because I'm focused on
crawl for AI, not rag um and chromadb
too much in this video. So, I'll just
say how do I install langraph? We'll see
if we can get the instructions for that
as well through the documentation. Yeah,
pip install lang graph really basic.
Maybe the LLM would have been able to
get this just with its own knowledge,
but I know that it's searching through
the database under the hood and we saw
that it definitely needed to do that for
things like crawl for AAI and Pantic AI.
So yeah, this is working great. So, I
know that in general I haven't covered
the nitty-gritty details of the code
that much in this video because I wanted
to give you a very highlevel overview of
how this agent works, how you can scrape
websites in different ways, and you can
just use this repository as your
template to get you started. You can
take the functionality from any of these
examples if you want to pull a specific
method or you can take a look at all the
details how I implemented that agent
that I just demonstrated for you. And so
with that, the last thing that I want to
show you is just a quick dive into each
of these different strategies, how that
works within crawl for AAI. I just want
to give you a more higher level idea of
how these strategies are implemented.
Starting with the first one for crawling
our site maps. And obviously since this
is just more of a demo script showing
you at a high level how to use the
sitemap crawler, I just have the URL
hardcoded here. It was dynamic with that
insert doc script that I showed you in
the demo. Here it's just hard-coded, but
we get the contents of the sitemap and
then we extract all the URLs from it
that we want to crawl and then we call
this crawl parallel function. We can
also determine how many URLs it's going
to process in each batch when it's doing
things in parallel. And so within this
crawl parallel, we set up a lot of
things to manage the memory for our
crawl for AAI instance that I don't want
to get into right now. But then we
create the async web crawler. And so
that's exactly what we created in that
very first example like we saw right
here. And now we're just going to use
the A run mini function. So instead of
just the basic A run function, we want
to crawl many URLs in parallel with
these batches that we set up. And so
it's going to get the markdown from all
these pages at the same time. And then
we can chunk that and insert that into
our vector database. And so this script
stops because it's just an example. it
stops at the point that we get the
markdown for that page just here in the
results. But you can take this
functionality, bring it into your own
agents just like I did for mine right
here. Like I took this functionality in
script number three in that example and
I baked that into my insert docs. So if
it detected that it needed to scrape a
sitemap file like using this function
right here, then we would call the
functionality that is very similar to
what we saw in the example script to
crawl in batches where we're going to
use the A-on mini just on all these URLs
getting them all from our site map. So
that is number three. And then for
number four, things look a lot different
because we just have to scrape a single
page. And so really we take the URL and
then with that URL we're going to call
the AUN function. So just like we called
a run in our very simple example to
crawl one page, we're doing the same
thing here. But because that's so
simple, I just took this as an
opportunity to also show you a little
bit more complex logic for some chunking
strategies that I've been playing around
with. And so I could do an entire video
on chunking strategies. And I might
actually do that soon. But what I do
with a markdown is I split based on
headers. And so I chunk all of the
documents based on the primary headers
like just with that single pound. And
then I also chunk based on the
subsections that we have as well. So we
have a bunch of these chunks now that
are the core sections split up for the
documentation that we crawled within
this single lm.ext page. And then I also
played around with some more chunking
strategies within insert docs. If you
want to take a look at my chunking
function here as well, I call it smart
chunk markdown. You can definitely take
a look at this. I don't have the time to
dive into this right now. Um, but there
are a lot of strategies for working with
markdown specifically because the
documents are formatted so nicely with
these headings and subheadings. You can
work with that to really make sure that
you split documents well, but also do it
in a way where the distinct sections are
all kept together in those chunks. You
don't lose that contextual information.
So, that is number four. And then our
last strategy is crawling websites
recursively because now we don't have a
sitemap to guide us. We don't have an
LMS.ext to bring everything together for
us. We just have a single URL and we
want to dynamically determine all of the
pages that we need to scrape based on
what we have in the navigation for this
homepage. Like right here we have the
homepage for the Pantic AI
documentation. And so we pass that into
this crawl recursive batch where we have
a list of start URLs. So this can also
handle more than one starting web page
if you want and it's going to use the A-
run many function to scrape all these
URLs loop through these results and then
the key part to this entire workflow is
that we can access what are called
internal links in crawl forai. So we get
the result like we get the markdown back
from the web page and then we can call
result.link.get and then get the
internal links. are called internal
because we're looking for links where
the domain is the same as the original
page that we scraped. That's how we're
able to navigate between all the
different pages that we have in the
website as a whole. And so we're going
to get a list of all of these URLs that
it fetches from these internal links.
And then we're just going to loop back
up to the top here just based on that
depth that I talked about earlier. And
we're going to call those web pages as
well. So we go deeper and deeper just
scraping all these links dynamically as
we go until we hit that depth limit of
three or five or whatever you have and
then finally we have a bunch of markdown
from all these different websites that
we visited that we can return. And so
this basically builds up a site map
dynamically over time. So the site map
is still better. It's more reliable if
you have that because then you're
guaranteed to have all the different
links. But this is just a nice way to be
more flexible if you're running into a
page and you'll see this a lot that
doesn't have a site map. So those are
the three strategies and how I've
implemented them. And again, take these
and implement them for yourself. I put a
lot of time into learning crawl for AAI
and getting all this set up for you. So
please use this as a resource and also
take a look at more of the code with my
padantic AI agent and things with
Chromma DB. So you can see how I set
that up if you are curious as well. So,
the last thing that I want to talk about
that very much relates to what we were
just covering with Crawl forAI is
Archon. This is my open- source AI agent
builder, and I'm thinking about making
some big changes with it. So, please
hear me out on this. If you care about
Archon, you've got some feedback for me.
I want to share with you my ideas that I
have for where I want to take Archon.
And then I want to know in the comments
what you think about what I'm planning
on doing here. And so at a high level,
Archon is able to both ingest
documentation for things like Pyantic AI
in its knowledge base and then also code
the agent itself. So it's multi-purpose
in isolation. It itself is enough to
create a full AI agent for you. But what
I'm thinking about doing is turning it
into a better version of something like
Context 7. So, context 7 is an MCP
server that you add into your AI coding
assistance to give it more knowledge to
work with different tools and frameworks
like MongoDB or Superbase or MCP,
whatever that might be. And I like this
a lot. The context 7 MCP server itself
doesn't create any code, but it provides
knowledge for the AI coding assistants
to do so. And right now with Archon, I'm
kind of tripping over the toes of AI
coding assistance because you can
integrate it with Windsurf or Cursor,
anything like that. But when it
generates the code for the agent, the AI
IDE then also has to generate the code
as well to put it into the files. So you
have a lot of duplicate work there which
is prone to errors. That's why I'm
thinking about maybe turning Archon more
into a knowledgebased specific project
like focusing a lot more on rag to help
AI coding assistants build agents
instead of it itself creating the agent
code. Because another thing that I've
been thinking about just as I've been
diving into processes for using AI
coding assistance, like there's so much
functionality that's already there
within things like wind surf and cursor
that I just want to leverage that and
then just have archon be the knowledge
engine behind the scenes instead of
trying to just do it all. I think we'll
get better results overall. It'll also
just make archon more expandable like we
can more easily add more documentation
into it kind of like we have here with
context 7. So it can be useful for a lot
more things than just building agents as
well. Like right now it's very limited
to only podantic AI and soon lang graph
and we're adding some more frameworks
and stuff into it. But I think being
able to just focus more on the knowledge
engine under the hood. That's what a lot
of people have been telling me as well
is like they're actually more excited
for that part of Archon versus the
actual code generation because AI coding
assistants are already knocking that out
of the park. And so that's enough of me
babbling about what I'm planning on
changing here. It is a really big shift
though because I'm focusing I'm very
much honing in on one component of
Archon now. But I think this is best for
the future of Archon. But it is a big
decision. So please let me know what you
think. That's what I've got going on for
Archon right now. I hope that this video
has really helped you level up your RAG
game, taking pretty much any website and
bringing it into your Vector database.
And also I have a lot more RAG content
coming soon, especially covering
different strategies for RAG that I
haven't talked about much on my channel
before. I really want to cover these
things like hierarchical rag, contextual
retrieval, query expansion, read
ranking. There are so many different
strategies that also go along well with
what we just covered with crawl for AI.
So definitely stay tuned for that. If
you appreciated this content and you're
looking forward to more things ragg and
AI agents, I would really appreciate a
like and a subscribe. And with that, I
will see you in the next